nicolas yves les habitants disent que la
nuit a été calme ce matin on a entendu
seulement quelques tirs d'artillerie
alors selon plusieurs sources locales
les soldats ukrainiens ont
contre-attaqué dans un village au nord
de la ville à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de la ville il l'aurait
repris aux soldats russes même si la
situation reste encore confuse ce que
l'on voit c'est que les troupes russes
qui sont aux portes de nicolas yves
essayer de contourner cette ville de 500
mille habitants repart le nord avec
l'objectif d'atteindre la route qui
relie odessa et kiev pour pouvoir la
coupe et les soldats ukrainiens qui sont
postés amicaux live oppose une forte une
forte résistance qu'on nous dit ici un
selon plusieurs sources qu à la morgue
de nicolas yves il y à autant de corps
de civils que de soldats les soldats
ukrainien qui voit également la tactique
russe changer quelque peu à 1 d'après
eux les russes essayent maintenant
d'avancer au nord encore une fois par
petits groupes pour éviter de manoeuvrer
sur les grands axes dans la ville de
nicolas even comme un peu partout on
voit une réelle solidarité des habitants
acquis qui collecte de la nourriture qui
collecte des médicaments pour ses
soldats il ya une vraie unité amicaux la
ive c'est vrai qu'on sent ici et c'est
ce que nous disent les habitants qu'il y
a une responsabilité parce que tant que
micola yves tiens eh bien c'est la
grande ville portuaire d'odessa 100 km à
l'ouest qui est protégé